we want you to be able to head out into
the world actually Mary do me a favor
and just game the door for me thank you
we want you to be able to head out into
the world and not get ripped off and get
the most value for money and so you'll
frequently see situations like this
where you need to make a choice about
which is actually going to end up being
cheaper now we know in general when you
see the same item you know maybe it's
like a um a bag of sugar or something
like that and you can see two different
sizes in general which is cheapest in
general is it the smaller one or the
bigger one interesting okay now you'll
pay less initially for a smaller one
clearly but usually there's an incentive
to buy em do you know what you call it
well cry buy in bulk right the more they
can sell you the cheaper they're happier
to sell it to you for now this is
usually the case but we want to number
one confirm that and number two be able
to spot when it's not because it isn't
always so we're gonna have a go at this
particular comparison and there's
roughly speaking two ways we could do it
they're kind of two versions of the same
theme so Merrick's you want to give us a
suggestion what we could do first okay
pause right there so I want to take
Marik's suggestion but don't know if we
all caught it
Mary suggested that we take this money
right and we divide it by the number of
grams that we've got in this case that's
45 you might want to get your calculator
out for this part because we're going to
get some weird numbers here so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to divide each of
these by 45 okay so that means I'm gonna
get some amount of money for one gram
okay now this is a small amount of money
you can divide by 45 so it's gonna be
pretty small some number of cents I'm
guessing has someone got an answer for
me I'm expecting you're getting zero
point zero something what do you got for
lots of sixes four six six repeater and
so on okay so that's how much it costs
for one gram using this bag okay and we
can do the same thing over here we can
take this different 6.50 we're not going
divided by 45 though this time we're
gonna divide by 150 could sinu
of maths right so what are we gonna get
for one gram in this case okay so very
close but instead of sixes we've got
three said okay does that match what you
got before married were you gonna do
something different yeah okay we're
happy with that so we can quickly see
which one is actually cheaper it's the
the bigger one per mass right of course
it costs more to get more but you're
actually getting more for your value
okay
now this way works it's fine but there
is another way that might actually be a
bit simpler yeah II have a question go
ahead well I'm going to show you the
other way and then I'm gonna let you
guys tell me which one you think is
easier okay okay
well let's have a look okay now what
we've done is this method by the way you
might want to jot this down it's called
the unitary method let me just write
that at the top here for you the unitary
method could I get a show of hands who's
heard that phrase before I think some of
you should have unitary method hands up
a few of you okay thinking hands down so
why do we call it the unitary method
what you're trying to get is the cost of
one unit in this case it was a grand it
might have been a kilogram or you know
how many doughnuts you get the unit
changes depending what you're buying
okay there's the unit there's the unit
now there's another way to do this the
whole idea is to be able to compare them
on the same terms one gram one gram but
there's an easier number and I want you
to look carefully don't shout it out but
I want you to raise your hand what's
your share there's an easier number that
we can get between 45 grams and 150
grams that's really quite easy to sort
of divide you don't your calculator at
all have a think what do you see here 15
15 grams if I worked out for 15 grams
how do I get from 45 to 50 what I'd have
died by I'll divide by 3 so that means I
should divide this by 3 as well you
don't need to calculate it for this
what's that divided by 3 70 cents so
that's zero point seven dollars 70 cents
have a look over here we reason why here
chose 15 is because it's real easy to
get
stayin out of this as well right I'm
going to divide by 150 I'm not going to
divide by three what should i divide by
10 which again you can tell me 65 cents
which confirms what we got before that
this is cheap do you see that 65 cents
versus 70 which did you like better the
blue method or the red one the red one
it's nice because you sort of don't have
to think as hard you just like whatever
amount is there just divide by that
whatever amount is there just divide by
that but I would like to put a big like
thumbs up on the blue method as well
because you noticed we all did the
calculations very simply and you know
even though you've got a calculator in
your pocket most of the time it really
pays to be able to do some things just
without thinking okay